Film Courage: How many people were involved
in starting your production company?
Now, how many people are involved?
Van Ditthavong, Filmmaker/Photographer:
When I started it was me and my wife.
Now it’s me with…one…two…four other
folks and a whole bunch of interns
and a roster of really great creatives
and directors. It’s become a little group.
I’m very fortunate to find teammates who want
to go through the battlefield of being part of
a production company. We started out small like
anyone just sitting out there How do people do it?
What do you have to do. So I just started
and I didn’t worry about the equipment.
If there was a bigger job to do we would rent it.
I didn’t want to buy 20, 30, 40,000 dollars worth
of equipment and have it sit there for a year or
two and let it depreciate and not get its value.
Everything has taken a hit now with 2020. We also
had a sales rep that represents goPOP FILMS and
directors in the midwest and southeast. They pitch
the ad agencies and art directors on our roster.
If there are treatments or spots or things
that we could bid on. We also go direct to
brand or direct to companies that need video
content. But at the moment obviously production
is picking up but you want to be safe. That’s the
key, low overhead so you can maintain and sustain
so when the economy comes up you will be able to
position yourself. If we think about it right now
as we are in preproduction, so when production
comes we are ready to go being ready to service
our clients to the best of our ability. I think
that’s where we are at right now in the 2020 era.
Film Courage: Right and with other
booms and busts with say the DotCom
when things were really good in
the 1990’s…can you talk about
not getting too confident knowing that there
will be a winter, there is always a winter.
Van: Yes, the life cycle of things.
You just have to be steady and know
especially with this you might have a lot of
clients or maybe your business has one big
client but what if they disappear? What if your
client was a lot of the travel industry right now?
But what if you weren’t busy, you also have
a plastic company and they’re needing a lot
of things so it just all depends where your
position in the market changes. You just have to
be…what is the saying? Expect the worse, prepare
for the best. It’s one of those things where you
can’t be a fat cat, you just keep going
because there will be lean times and the
same with films when films come out. We just
released our film [ALL ROADS TO PEARLA]. We
don’t know where the market, that’s the
toughest thing about filmmaking because
you have the thing that you made that you started
3, 4, 10 years ago but when it reaches market
is it the right time for this film? Does this
touch a nerve? Is it 2 years too early, 2 years
too late? So it’s the same when you release your
product. Is it right or not? Maybe it catches on
later. What was that with DONNIE DARKO, it wasn’t
so hot here in The States, it goes international,
comes back, it’s a five year process. It happens
with a lot of different things. For anyone who has
had a short film or other film I think you
go back and focus on that creating because
you can’t determine the market but you can prepare
for it. I think that's the balance you have to do.
Be prepared for lean times and that
would be the best way to go about it.
Film Courage: What area of business
does your production company focus on?
Van: We have a lot of different directors whether
it’s healthcare, food, fashion, documentaries.
We cover a lot of different industries, we can
tackle them all. I figured this out because
when I was a director trying to
get into a production company,
I wasn’t going to get hired for a comedy spot
because my reel or my work isn’t comedic. I
wasn’t going to get hired for food because
I didn’t do any food. I had a documentary
feel. Those are the different jobs
that I would get (more cinematic). So
I thought we will have our company instead of
turning down jobs, let’s find the best directors
who does food, who does cars, who does fashion,
who does travel, and that’s your roster.
If you’re a client who needs cinematic images that
need to have your brand or message elevated and
tell a story, that is what we do. We want to help
you tell your story. That's our selling point.
Bringing cinematic imagery and production to
elevate your brand and your company’s message.
So it could be the wine industry, it could
be fashion, we pretty much tackle it.
Film Courage: How do you know these
directors are a fit for your company?
Van: Sure, so when we see the director’s work
and it has to be a certain level and certain
voice that they’re telling. Second, I
meet with them and if they have a certain
philosophy or personality because we don’t want to
work with jerks, there are already so many walking
around. We want to work with good people who are
focused on producing really good work and also
are nice. We have this motto of “Work hard and
be nice.” Of that aspect so the directors not
only have to be talented but just have to be nice
people because when we are on set and when you’re
dealing with clients, who wants a temperamental
director? It’s like we should be fortunate to be
working for you. I want to be surrounded by people
of that same attitude of like how can we help you?
It’s like business…you can’t take anything
for granted. Every little job, every big job,
it’s a job. It should be treated the same,
highly valuable. I remember Neiman Marcus
someone was telling me the sales training or
someone’s training as you treat everyone who
walks in the door the same. Someone who can
look like their transient versus someone who
has on a mink coat. You never know who is who. So
that’s the same thing with an email, with a call,
with your client base. We are just fortunate to
be able to see if we can help you. That’s the
type of directors and if they have that attitude
and they want to put their nose to the grind
and then they do. Funny enough, a lot of our
directors have a background in photography
(similar to me) so they are actually starting
out as photographers too so it's nice to have.
I know visually that they could capture what
they want. They could actually act as their own
DP [director of photography] or
work with DPs or things like that.
Funny enough a lot of our
directors are shooters themselves.
Film Courage: And want’s interesting sometimes,
just like you said the mink coast versus the
transient analogy sometimes in Los Angeles the
mink coat…the more show…the less someone has.
That’s the weird part of being here and maybe
this is the same in New York City too but a lot
of times that’s just a front and is not real.
Van: Exactly, you just never know and
so those are the types of directors or graphic
designers or animators or people who want to
work with, even our crew. They always say
it starts from the top and hopefully we can
create a culture that is professional but also
creates that atmosphere where your voice is heard.
No one is above anyone else. Everyone is open
to suggestions and everyone is artistic but
we don’t need to be Van Gogh here and
be all crazy if you don’t get your way.
Film Courage: What are your day-to-day duties with
your company maybe pre-2020 and now during 2020?
Van: You get up, you fire up that laptop or
that desktop and you go through your emails.
A lot right now “Let’s talk” since it’s
2020, research (a lot of research going on).
In terms of new clients that we want to work with
or we’re in a new industry, we have a new industry
that we’re trying to penetrate is the golf and
luxury resort industry prior to 2020. We’ve got a
couple of great directors who do that so we
are trying to match that up. Now that’s the
commercial side but for the film side I have a
couple of different films in development right now
and one is we’re shaping up a script to go out
for attachments and things like that so the last
couple of months I’ve been trying to get
that script right. We are also producing this
feature film for this Dutch filmmaker
Yfke van Berckelaer (her first
feature film). Her short film LILY has
been screened in over 50 film festivals
around the world. It’s a Me Too horror film.
And Phosphor one of her first feature films
we are fortunate enough to be producing that so
we’re trying to get things lined up for for that.
Like we were talking about before there are
still a lot of things that could be done
even though everyone is getting used to Zoom and
all this stuff but it is laying the seeds and
getting all that done. That takes most of the day.
We just released the film [ALL ROADS
TO PEARLA] to weeks ago September 25th
last month so we’re still pushing that as well.
Lots of little different things on our plate.
Film Courage: Was pre-2020 responding
and post-2020 or during 2020
is now hunting, doing research?
Van: Yes, hunting, doing research
because you don’t know who is going to be
left standing. It’s a weird thing. We
were talking with our sales agent where
we’ve released our film for North America
but we are still entertaining international
territories like Germany, UK, Ireland and all
of these other parts but because of 2020 and
different things companies have gone under so
it’s almost like everyone is waiting to see
what is left, who is standing. Everyone is
adjusting so you kind of have to take an
optimistic point and do your research
and tread water until there is a break.
It’s very interesting, for commercial
work we had a lot of shoots postponed,
canceled things like that so you deal with
the blows, you take it on the chin but you’ve
got to still stand up and
prepare as when things open up.
Question For The Viewers: What part
of this video was most helpful to you?